[Music]
what's interesting to me is we will use
AI as we have been to specifically
target tasks that we need or want done
in place of ourselves
that's how AI will ultimately unfold I
think AI is going to open a new chapter
of the society of the world that people
try to understand ourselves better
rather than the outside world with AI
especially I'm really optimistic and I
think that people who are naysayers and
kind of try to drum up these doomsday
scenarios are I just I don't understand
it I think it's it's it's really
negative and it and in some ways I
actually think it's it's pretty
irresponsible because doing the next
five to ten years
AI is gonna deliver so many improvements
and the quality of our lives
it is a renaissance it is a golden age
we are now solving problems with machine
learning and artificial intelligence
that were you know kind of in the realm
of science fiction for the last several
decades AI is probably the most
important thing humanities that has ever
worked on now I think of it as something
more profound and electricity or fire
and anytime you work with technology you
need to learn to harness the benefits
and while minimizing the downside
[Music]
is we're focusing on autonomous systems
and clearly one purpose of autonomous
systems is self-driving cars there are
others and we sort of see it as the
mother of all AI projects your AI is
already helping us basically diagnose
diseases better match up drugs with
people depending on what they're sick
that's that way they can get treated
better so it's gonna help a whole lot of
people get treated and get better
healthcare than would have had access to
it before if you look at self-driving
cars they're going to be safer than than
people driving cars I would say a lot of
the value that we're getting from
machine learning is actually happening
you know kind of beneath the surface and
it is things like improved search
results improved product recommendations
for customers improve forecasting for
inventory management and and and
literally hundreds of other things
beneath the surface there's a class of
things like game playing or speech
recognition or image recognition that
the performance levels are phenomenal
you know if you compare human speech
recognition to computer speech
recognition the computer is slightly
better and that's you know mind-blowing
certainly we use AI to do drug discovery
these biological systems are very
complicated and so the fact that we have
vaccines for TB and HIV coming that's
partly enabled by this rich data
advanced in biology and machine learning
and I look at seeing AI which is an
application we just launched for anybody
with visual impairment they can go
download this app that uses the latest
cutting-edge computer vision technology
in our cloud to give anyone the ability
to see and in fact Angela mills was a
colleague of mine was just telling me
about how it's changed her life inside
of Microsoft she can go into our
cafeteria or the fool using this app
with confidence walk into conference
rooms with confidence because she knows
she's walking into the right conference
room or what we've done with our OneNote
and Word
learning tools anyone who has dyslexia
can now use AI to be able to read better
if the latest release of Windows 10 has
this capability called IJ's which is
something that we learned working with
Steve Gleason and the ALS patients to
saying if you all you have is the eye
muscle that the gaze can we help you
type yeah you don't have to be careful
when there's advances in a sense we're
all better off if if the machines can
make all the food and the clothes and
none of us have to work you know you
think ok now we have all the freedom if
we want to stand behind the counter and
you know make sandwiches ok you can if
you want but there's this other way to
make those goods and services but it
will be very disruptive because you know
say you're mid-career in manufacturing
or driving then it's a disruption now
we've had that in a slow way for
hundreds of years you know we used to
all be farmers now very few of us are
farming I said it's right to be
concerned absolutely you have to worry
about it otherwise you're not going to
solve it right and it's important to
understand tomorrow whether Google is
there or not
you know artificial intelligence is
going to progress you know technology
has just nature it's that it's going to
evolve
I think pulling back history shows
pulling back countries which pull back
don't do well with the change we know
that 23 years ago
you educated yourself and that carried
you through for the rest of your life
that is not going to be true for the
generation which is both being born now
they have to learn continuously over
their lives we know that so we have to
transform how we do education look I
think I mean you nailed it anything
that's repetitive and done you know on
the back of you know technology or you
know is going to be fundamentally
vulnerable yeah so I think technology
and in particular AI can in fact bring
more empowerment more inclusiveness and
at the same time we should be clear-eyed
about displacement clear-eyed about
unintended
consequences like any other technology
and work both skilling so that you know
people can find the jobs of the future
create new jobs and lastly I think have
a set of policy decisions that really
help people as they go through this
change people already unhappy because a
lot of machine learning artificial
intelligence purely random job people
start to worry those the background they
think the education background if you
can not if you're not innovative enough
if you're not like a creative enough
your job will be taking away by a lot of
machines the risks are important and I
think the way we solve it is we think
ahead we worry about it we do things
like from from be upfront you know have
ethical charters think about AI safety
from day one be very transparent and
open and how we perceive progress there
and figure out global frameworks by
which we can engage just like Paris
agreement and climate change you know
using forums like this I think we bring
people together they engage on the hard
questions and I think answers will
emerge you know I have exposure to the
very most cutting-edge AI and I think
people should be really concerned about
it I keep so much sounding we long bell
but you know until people see like
robots going down the street killing
people like they don't know how to react
you know because it seems so ethereal
and I think we should be really
concerned about AI and I think we should
this is AI is a rare case where I think
we need to be proactive in regulation
instead of reactive because I think by
the time we are reactive in AI
regulation it's too late right now we
have machine learning algorithms that
can solve an incredibly complex problem
beyond any human intelligence but
they're essentially Complete Idiot's and
like two-year-olds and anything that's
not that problem they're dumb
the head like that you can give them
this enormous data set and they come up
with brilliant correlations and insights
but they're not going to plug in the
Skynet and like threaten us anytime soon
so I'm quite optimistic and I don't
think artificial intelligence is a
threat I don't think that fish
intelligent is something terrible but
human being a smart enough to learn that
[Music]